so should we talk a little bit about the
the stupid that's coming out of medical
academia another academia that sounds
like fun yeah it's always fun ok Zack
put this up a few would sweetie
Australian doctors push renaming Adam's
apple the Achilles tendon and other
misogynistic terms this is for real this
is not in the onion or whatever
Australia's version of the onion is I
can't remember at the moment I mean
these things really speak for themselves
but my god so there are a lot of body
parts that are named for the people who
dis who were the first people in Western
science to discover them and of course
until very recently that was mostly
limited to you know landed white men and
okay fine what are we doing and the
Adam's apple and Achilles tendon these
aren't even real people guys like this
is mythology this is mythology and
Achilles was a great warrior I don't
maybe he was real but the Adam's apple
is an ugly lump we're gonna rename one
of the parts that's actually only in
Owen man
yeah so I don't even have much more on
that it's just so absurd well no here's
the what's more I mean it's funny but
it's so unfunny because the answer is
people are not extrapolating right yeah
this is the level of thinking of the
people who tell you they know what we're
supposed to do next
Yeah right this is the level of the
string right and then like and the kind
of language they use is often decolonize
decolonize our language and in fact the
next example is is that two grammar
Rutgers English department to
de-emphasize traditional grammar quote
in solidarity with black lives matter
yeah please
I just read the headline of what what
you guys can now see the chair of the
Rutgers English department sent out an
email announcing plans to decolonize
again English by in part focusing less
on grammar quote this approach from the
Department of English at Rutgers email
to her people
this approach challenges the familiar
dogma that writing instruction should
limit emphasis on grammar and sentence
level issues so as to not put students
from multilingual non-standard academic
English backgrounds at a disadvantage so
we can steal man this briefly and say I
have actually taught with faculty who
were really good at grammar level
correction and didn't weren't really
able to see the bigger you know why do
we write in the first place we don't
write to have perfect grammar we write
in order to say something right so they
focus entirely on grammar is misguided
and will kill the spirit and creativity
of the best students and you know
actually all students I think and so
should writing instruction be focused
also on content and big ideas and not
exclusively on copy editing but also on
editing and actual content of course it
should and too many writing teachers
don't do that I don't know if it's
because they can't or because they're
lazy or because they honestly think that
grammar is the end all and be all but
the idea that grammar shall that
everyone shall not be held to the
standards of of grammar including this
isn't just for undergraduate papers
who's suggesting this for dissertations
for PhD level dissertations this is the
soft bigotry of low expectations this
that is exactly what this is trying to
help people help help people by assuring
them that they won't be held to
standards that's not helping them that's
not helping them in any way it's beyond
the soft bigotry of low expectations
[Music]
because the obviously correct thing is
that these things are readily learning
and we've done a terrible job of
democratizing the tools to do it and the
right thing to do is to democratize
those tools to pretend that there is
something within certain populations
that puts correct grammar out of reach
is an insane insult I mean it's it's
Robyn D'Angelo all over again like this
this department chair is either so
confused and scared by the inaccurately
named black lives matter movement or is
actually personally a racist and really
believes that people from backgrounds
that aren't like hers can't do very well
it's one of those two things I think
like what what are the other
possibilities on the table the this is
it but the other thing which I never see
anybody say is alright or actually
occasionally see people say this now if
you Institute these standards you are so
hobbling us nationally that you are
guaranteeing we lose our position going
forward right if our PhDs cannot speak
with precision because nobody has
required it of them then they will not
speak with precision what will happen to
the quality of discourse if people who
are responsible for discourse do not do
it with precision well then our thinking
will degrade right what happens in the
School of Engineering when you decide
that logic and math are white
supremacists well you stop doing logic
and math well what happens sooner or
later the bridges start falling down how
long do you imagine we can impose this
nonsense on all of the systems that
actually do make things work and not
have them come apart and it's totally
consistent with the idea that hierarchy
is itself racist or sexist or whatever
is do you want to choose right the idea
if the idea of hierarchy is itself a
problem then you can't have better and
worse you you can't actually have
assessment of quality because quality
itself if hierarchy doesn't exist and
quality doesn't exist you know right
there there is there is no ranking
possible on any level which is a
conflation of you know equal under the
law with every single individual is
identically capable of all things which
no one in their right mind would claim
yeah every single individual is not
equal and equally capable of all things
even if we managed to completely
equalize all opportunity for a moment
for a moment one we simply very that's
that is the result of evolution so one
way to think about this is the level of
insanity of the claims that are now
regularly surfacing the level of
insanity is a direct measure of the
strength of the underlying game theory
of this movement in other words can you
spell it out the feebleness of the
argument floats on the fact that it is
very difficult to oppose it without
paying a price right and it is that
thing so it's this move where the idea
is here is a thing and you have to say
it and if you resist then you are the
thing that is being alleged so if you
say for example that you know logic is
not a white trait then you are engaged
in anti black racism so the point is
people then say that it is a white trait
doing all kinds of harm in the process
but they do that and what happens is
they get an immediate it's it's it's
addiction this thing how do you get
addicted to your phone
somebody has figured out how to trigger
these little releases of dopamine and
they'd get you coming back for more so
if you feel a threat and then somebody
is capable of removing that threat you
may figure out how to do the thing that
keeps getting the threat to back off and
what are you doing you're becoming an
accomplice to the movement that's how
you're getting the threat to back off
but of course it's utterly free to make
a threat it's it's in this context it is
free to make a threat it is free to
attack a federal building there's all
kinds of things that have become free
and so what I think we're watching day
in and day out at all sorts of levels is
people serving their own immediate
interests motivated by fear and
emboldened the movement that is creating
the fear it you know it's it's the the
child who sends the adults into the
cornfield
and the thing is eventually you have to
confront the child because there's no
there's no solution that comes from
everybody you know saying what the child
wants you to say and that's what we're
looking at ya know it feels it feels
ever more juvenile but this these aren't
these aren't reasonable children young
man this this is a topic for many many
many of their conversations as you know
as as we have had as we have raised our
own children and written about childhood
on what child it is and how it is that
you make strong and resilient and
awesome and humor filled and and loving
children into adults you do not cater to
their every whim and you do not run
scared when they throw a tantrum you
don't cave to Tantrums ever and if what
you do is you say don't do that or I'll
X and they keep doing it and you don't
do X they do it more of course they do
that is basic human psychology of course
they do more of it and that is exactly
what we're seeing on our streets it's
exactly what we're seeing in boardrooms
of proceeding in colleges it's what
we're seeing every place this is really
badly raised children in the bodies of
adults acting like maybe they were
taught to act by their parents who
didn't know how to parent and never said
no and you know imagine that that's all
taking place on a ship and what they're
doing is they're getting us to allow
them to take apart the ship on which we
all depend including them
[Music]